[Applause]
Thanks it's nice to be here nice to be
here in Miami you know it's good to see
a Python community down you know down
down here I've actually spent a lot of
my life in South Florida not a lot of
people know that but uh you know between
like family and so forth so I probably
spent like a couple years you know over
the last 25 or 30 years down down here
so nice to be it's nice to be back in
the Sun got really it got down I just
moved to Nashville Tennessee and it's uh
it doesn't get cold there and it got
cold just as I was leaving so you know
perfect so so last year I for a variety
of reasons I I founded a non-profit open
source development group and this is not
the time the kind of thing that you hear
about happening very often usually when
people want to work on an open-source
project it's you know something that
they're working on as their hobby like
they work on it you know on nights and
weekends and you know they push code to
github you know unfortunately you know
recently we've seen you know some major
security breaches in the node package
manager and in some of those cases it
was like hey I was just having fun
building the software and somebody came
along and wanted to maintain this module
and I said sure and they didn't bother
you know verifying their identity and
you know there were certain protocols
that we're not followed but you know I
think a lot of people do open source
because it's fun and if it weren't fun
well you know probably a lot less of us
a lot less of us would do it you know
people do people do open source for many
other reasons often it's because they're
solving a problem that they have at work
and they for whatever reason they want
to give the work that they're doing
either you know send the contributions
upstream into another open source
project or they feel like
you know they've built something that's
interesting and it's filling a gap that
exists in the world and so they decide
to open source it and you know pandas
which I understand that many people use
started out as a closed source library
and we I admit I made the pitch this was
like early 2009 it's like hey it would
be really great if we had you know a
nice library that a lot of people used
or you know that a lot of people use
that made data easy to work with you can
read data files you can manipulate it
you can do analytics you know it'll be
great so I think you know at that time
there was sort of skepticism like oh
well you know are people even going to
want to do this work in Python at all
and that you know now at least people
you know nobody asked that question
anymore hmm
but there's other you know people build
up open source projects in other ways
sometimes they sometimes they start
companies and so lately you know you've
probably seen a lot of articles
everyone's sort of wringing their hands
because it's very difficult for open
source projects to have successful
business models when Amazon Web Services
or you know another you know software
company that doesn't do a lot of open
source can take the software build a
software as a service offering and then
not give any code back to the project
and so you know we've seen many high
profile open source projects like Redis
Apache Kafka or not Kafka itself but
confluent the company that it one of the
companies started by the founders of
Kafka so companies have been changing
their licenses essentially to try to
make it harder for AWS and and friends
to take from the open source world and
not get it back and so it's getting
harder and harder to build open source
software sustainably and so you know as
I been working on the arrow project for
a little over three years and and
you know I decided I didn't like really
I didn't like any of the the models for
funding the work that I saw particularly
given how low at how how how much the
the project is an infrastructure project
it's not a product it's not like a
service that you set up and run it's not
a database it's not something that could
be turned into an Amazon service
offering maybe some part of it could but
you know I wanted to really you know
have a group of engineers who are
focused on you know building high
quality software that the world can
depend on and help the the ecosystem you
know the data science the ecosystem but
also many other programming communities
evolve their computational foundations
into the future so I've been doing that
and that's kept me pretty busy you know
over the last year or so
I mean thankfully we we have a number of
gracious gracious sponsors who are who
are funding the work we're growing a
team so so things are things are going
well so as part of this I I wanted to
partner with the our community and so
the first time people on the internet
found out that Hadley Wickham and I are
friends it sort of produced all of this
like what like our and Python people can
be friends with each other like isn't
that it's like not allowed right it's
like you know with cats and dogs like
you know montagues and capulets you know
that kind of thing and you know it's
like when I get together with people
from from the art community yeah we're
writing different code in different
programming languages but these days a
lot of us are writing C and C++ code a
lot of us are solving the exact same
problems but we're delivering solutions
to different communities the our
community happens to be more skewed
towards the academic statistics world
and certain you know and so and data
journalism and communities where the
Python Python hasn't historically had as
much had as much penetration
you know Python has more machine
learning and you know
kind of computer science different
different communities so so it's great
for us to be working together we we are
now five full-time engineers so I'm very
happy to be having putting five people
to work full-time just doing open source
software and nothing else we're also
working with some folks from the our
studio tiburce team people you may see
out in the wild contributing to Apache
arrow or other other projects and my
shameless plug is that we are still
hiring and so if you or anyone you know
would like a remote software engineering
position in a large open source project
you know please please let me know so we
have a number of sponsors so I so from
from the earth the get-go I partnered
with our studio to make the business of
growing a team of you know employees and
engineers easier for me so that I can
spend more time focused on building
software less time on running a business
and I have run a business in the past
like I founded a startup called datapad
six years ago and so I've been had the
experience of you know doing all the
accounting and business stuff and so I
wanted to do less of that and more more
software before before this eyes I spent
two years working with two sigma who had
you know or have been great you know
great sponsors of the aero project
Nvidia who are you know out in force
here at this conference are are
sponsoring the work we just received
sponsorship from the open data science
conference and you might think it's
weird I've got to put this on Twitter I
haven't done it yet just in the process
of updating the website but you might
think is interesting for a conference to
sponsor an open-source software
development group but I mean you think
about the relationship that conferences
have with open source software
conferences are growing and have revenue
because the open source software is
popular so it's not you know it's not
that strange and I hope that we see more
conference organizers giving money back
to
a token source so there's other ways
that sponsors can help so Nvidia just
donated these to like big workstations
which are now keeping my apartment
really toasty so I just don't even need
to turn the heat on anymore and you know
well I'm not that toasty because you
know cryptocurrency mining is not really
profitable right now so so we are only
running we're only running a CUDA for
Aero development and I'm probably not
supposed to joke about that it is a joke
after all so but it's it's it's great to
have you know other kinds of support
because you know software development
requires tools you know we need tools
like these to be able to make sure that
we are you know building software that
can run on this kind of high-end
equipment which gets used in many
different environments so anyway so that
with all that out of the way I'm going
to get to the get to get to the
technical stuff so mm-hmm
I'm gonna make some broad
generalizations and so please please you
know don't nitpick the details too much
although nitpicking the details is
important but after you know after I
started working on the pandas project in
2008 and after five or six years you
know we had built you know we had built
the project you know myself and the
other other pandas developers had built
the project based on the technology that
was available essentially in 2007-2008
so that was numpy scipy matplotlib
ipython you know cpython itself and if
you think about if you think about numpy
and the scientific computing libraries
they in turn are providing a Python send
Python API to do array computing matrix
operations linear algebra using
techniques and software that was
available in the mid-90s and even before
that so there's like a lot of Fortran
code for linear algebra that was
available in the nineteen
in the 80s and 90s and even the 1970s
and so there's kind of this huge legacy
of computational software that is
powering modern data science and some of
it has scaled well to you know current
hardware and you know some of it has not
some of it also has to the problems have
to do with just you know the software
development soup andis was was built so
that every operation every line of code
every every function call is immediately
evaluated and so that works well when
your data is a megabyte but it doesn't
work that well when your data is a
terabyte so just things like the way
that code is evaluated has to change
when you want to think about working
with larger larger data sets when you're
working with a lot larger data sets the
way that you manage memory and the way
that you access data has to change in
order to be more scalable another
problem that I experienced and this is
partly in interacting with the our
community and other other you know open
source community is the fact that even
though we're solving many of the same
problems we are you know we're kind of
working independently like we don't we
don't collaborate very much you know we
don't share code very often if we all
have data frames and we say the word
data frame but if you go under the hood
our data frames look different and so
you know I I couldn't help but think
like well what if we could try to
address some of these problems and also
make it easier for the different
communities to collaborate and so in an
ideal world you know there's there's not
really any rocket science it turns out
that there's a you know rich literature
of computational techniques for
large-scale data processing you know the
analytic database world has been solving
large-scale data processing problems
since the 80s and 90s there's a rich
literature that can be mined for
techniques for working with a lot larger
data sets and tools like pandas so
ideally you know we would build
everything to be multi-core native you
know but now we have GPU
so you know even though Moore's law is
it's sort of over for CPUs like the
scalability curve is like still going
and going and going for GPUs so we have
to take advantage of that if we want to
keep scaling into the future we have all
these fancy runtime compiler tools so
gone are the days of having to hand
generate x86 like we can use LLVM to
generate code efficient code at runtime
we can think about how we can share you
know now that systems have become a lot
more heterogeneous we can think about
sharing data more efficiently between
systems so there's a lot of stuff we can
do and one point that I often make is
that the reason why we haven't had to
address these problems so much in the
past is precisely because of Moore's Law
and we've been able to say well you know
things aren't great but we'll just wait
a couple of years and things will just
you know magically become faster because
processors have get faster because
Moore's law also the RAM will get bigger
so you know more data fits in memory so
we can kind of just punt on on solving
on thinking about these problems so so
the arrow project was was conceived in
in 2015
kind of serendipitously as a group of
you know 2025 open-source developers
that I connected with mostly out on the
west coast who were key key people in
various big data projects and I had just
started working at Cloudera and I wanted
to somehow mind-meld the data science
world with folks in the big data and the
database community because traditionally
like I started telling them about pandas
and about data science and you know
dealing with a bunch of people with PhDs
and database systems and they have never
you know they don't know anything about
our Python they've never really
experienced this world and so there's
just this kind of like non there's
there's no has historically been no
collaboration happening and so what I
would like to see is to enable these
communities to collaborate and for the
data science world
be able to benefit from all of the
research and and ideas that have been
generated in the analytic database
community in the last in the last 30
years so the so when we started the
project the the single problem that we
wanted to solve was to define an open
standard for representing tabular data
in memory and so pandas has its own way
of representing data R has its own way
of representing data every sequel
database engine has its own internal
runtime format so you know we can't be
all things to all people but you know it
would be nice to have some kind of a
reasonable open standard that could be
used to power analytical applications so
thankfully three years have passed or
almost four years have passed since we
started even talking about the project
and so it turns out that a lot of people
agree that it is a problem and so you
know what we would like to see and I
understand that
Clemmie from from Nvidia also spoke
about this but we kind of want to get
away from this this world where we're
having to do all of this conversion
between point a and point B all the time
and at least have some kind of a way of
representing data at the memory level so
in RAM or on in shared memory like
memory maps we're assuming the two
systems know about arrow that they have
the option of sharing data with each
other using using arrow thing working I
use the keyboard so so now that time has
passed we started out with Java and C++
we're now up to 11 programming languages
so we most recently added c-sharp and
MATLAB to the mix so I think other
languages that we don't have that it
would be really interesting I'd like to
see Swift people are talking about Swift
so you know any Swift programmers like
this could be a project to work on we
have rust a lot of people are
programming and rust so but in terms of
the work that we're doing in the project
I am this
my opinionated view so we're focused in
a few key areas so the first is that we
want systems to be able to share data
and share code so if you want to share
code you need the data representation to
be the same otherwise you say well you
know this table looks a little bit
different from the you know what my code
expects so I have to convert it to my
expectation and then run my code so if
the data is an immutable standard than
if you have two algorithms which know
how to interact with Aero memory then
they don't have to be rewritten because
it's arrow is a brand new data
representation we have to implement
connectors into storage systems and file
formats and so we've been spending a lot
of time doing that we want to enable
systems to share data with each other
food it through different protocols so
whether that's through shared memory and
memory Maps or through through on a
network so if a system says hey you know
rather than going through ODBC or JDBC
or some other kind of database protocol
say here's my here's my port which
exposes arrow data
natively and so we can you know move
data around a network without having to
convert to some intermediate
representation so it's a so as you can
imagine this is very ambitious and it's
a difficult project to work on and we're
working kind of with two kind of
high-level goals so the first is that we
want the platform of libraries and all
these programming languages to be a
suitable development platform like a
foundation for new systems to be built
so if you are building a new database
you're building a new data frame library
you know maybe you're building like a
data micro service like you know this
you want to have a service that can
receive a table apply like a small
operation to it and then send the data
onward to some other service
we want to make those things easy to
build and we also want to be able to
retrofit existing systems with kind of
algorithms and tools that are coming out
of this out of this ecosystem so that
would be like you know like the pandas
ecosystem for example we'd like existing
data frame like data science projects to
be able to benefit from this alright I
use the keyboard so so it was kind of
like the mnemonic for you know thinking
about system architecture I didn't
intend to become a computer scientist I
was a mathematician it just you know
anyway so you know traditionally you
build a system and you build this kind
of vertically integrated thing where
you've got a you got a make your own
data structures you've got to build data
connectors you write your own algorithms
maybe you design your own file formats
if you need to move data around in a
distributed system you define a wire
format for moving data around so we we'd
like to develop standards to kind of
salt address all of these problems at
the same time so we have standard data
structures we don't have to serialize we
have reusable algorithms reasonable file
formats and we can move data in a
distributed system in a standard way
so if you ever look at the architecture
of a database system usually in a
database you just interact through the
front end the front end is often SQL
queries and you know the other parts of
the system you don't really see so
there's an in-memory like a way that
data is managed in memory there's the
query engine that does you know select
join group by where and so forth and
then there's backends storage and you
know there's you know I think one of the
things that the Hadoop ecosystem did
over the last ten years was decouple the
storage like the file persistent storage
from the database systems so this idea
of like bring your own database and like
all the data is in the Hadoop file
system and
now cloud storage like s3 and Google
Cloud storage has taken taken the role
of this as well
so so what we would like to do is kind
of decouple all of these components and
give them a public API so if you need to
store and serialize data we can do that
if we need to compute queries
traditionally databases would not expose
the details of their query engines to
library users but the thing is the
front-end that's kind of opinionated
like maybe some people like sequel some
people like code that looks like pandas
I don't want to dictate what what the
user API looks like so that if somebody
wants to build something that's eagerly
evaluated they can do that something
that's lazy something that's sequel we
can have many different ways of
interacting with these components that
don't require an opinionated interface
or even a pinyin ated programming
language so you wouldn't be required to
use Python or use our and in fact like
it's been really exciting that we were
working with folks in the Ruby community
in Japan who you know we write something
in C++ and within a few weeks we have
ways to interact with that code in our
Ruby and Python so it's sort of it's
kind of a brave new world like we've no
I've never you know worked on a project
like that before so it's kind of
rehashing the things that I was just
saying I said them out loud so I kind of
want to rewind or like at least take one
step back a little bit into the
practical domain of the of the pandas
user you say okay Wes like this all
sounds great you know we're gonna make
new systems really fast we're gonna make
systems more interoperable we're gonna
have all these libraries and all these
programming languages sounds great how
is that relevant to me because every day
I go into work and I write import pandas
as peedee peedee I read CSV and then I'm
off off to the races
so I
I did a I gave a presentation a little
over five years ago and the title of the
presentation was ten things I hate about
pandas and a lot of people thought that
was funny and but it was really kind of
constructive criticism about the
internal implementation problems of you
know kind of how pandas is implemented
like how it's designed and like why
those are causing issues and it was not
to say that you know some of these
things are fixable and so this was
before we had categorical and pandas and
so that's resolved some of the problems
with strings but in general like if you
have really big data that doesn't fit
into memory and you know ideally you
could memory map that very difficult to
do with pandas so people have been a
tackling have been tackling the out of
core very large data problem with other
tools like desk and desk has you know
been a great tool for helping scale
scale pandas the way that pandas
represents strings is really inefficient
so they use a ton of memory and there's
basically no way for computational code
to process them efficiently because
they're all in the Python object heap
and so if you've never really thought
about this like and this is a from from
my collaborator of a corns a slide deck
so if you have a pandas series like a
data frame column that has strings it's
representing those strings and an umpire
array that contains Python objects and
so each Python object has a pointer into
various objects all over the you know
wherever Python allocates strings so not
only is not only is the memory that
represents the string all over all over
the process heap but the the struct like
the C struct for the Python string is
large like it actually from Python to to
Python 3 it got bigger so if you're
using strings in Python 3 like I know
we're all really happy to like only be
using Python 3 now
right like it's 2020 it's almost here
[Laughter]
yeah it's like if this is more serious
than y2k really I mean yeah so you know
if you even if you have a string even an
empty string like an empty string in
Python 3 takes up 48 bytes think there's
just that you know it's length 0 48
bytes like there's no way around it so
but so one thing that that Suva who's
one of the arrow developers has been
able to do is use extension arrays in
pandas to extend extent I I already set
this up for myself to extend pandas with
with arrow string vectors which have
kind of like a packed kind of contiguous
memory representation they use a
fraction the amount of memory that
Python strings do at least the overhead
is like tight is four bytes instead of
48 per string and all the data is
contiguous so just by having a more
efficient representation use a lot less
memory you can process the strings a lot
a lot faster so
so there's some other things like you
know we're like allowing data to be
non-contiguous like having data frames
composed in multiple chunks we don't
really have tools for dealing with
nested types so I don't know if you've
ever run into that problem or you're
processing JSON you need to kind of like
unravel the whole data structure before
you can do anything so my view is like
we should have operators to just process
the data in place and do so efficiently
so each so these are problems that we're
that were we're tackling in a narrow
land so I've been talking a lot so I
don't want to run at a time but i'ma
tell you about a few things that we've
been doing that are cool where you know
the benefits of this work are playing
out
so one thing we did was my colleagues
from from T Sigma and also work folks
Brian Cutler from IBM so other folks and
folks in the SPARC community have been
involved at all is that we made custom
Python functions on spark run a lot
faster so now if you're using sparking
2.3 and higher there's now like a
special pandas UDF where you can write
extensions to spark sequel that use
pandas operations and have you know can
have like up to a hundred times better
performance and so it's a bit crazy that
the performance is so much better when
you consider how much work is actually
happening so when sparks sequel is
evaluating these these pandas UDF's it's
actually performing four separate
conversions to and from the arrow memory
layout so sparks sequel has its own
table layout because every system has
its own table this is kind of pre arrow
you know systems so it converts the
arrow we just get streamed over to the
Python worker process that gets
converted to pandas and we've gone crazy
making the conversion from arrow like as
fast as possible the Panda stop racing
is evaluated and then the data gets
streamed back to spark via via the arrow
format and even with all of those
conversions like we're still able to get
you know 100x speed-up in some cases so
you could imagine like how much well I
mean will fool guess we'll find out but
you could imagine how much better the
performance would be if both systems on
the left and right we're both using the
same memory representation didn't have
to do all this conversion I presume
since you've been at this conference
you've heard from folks on the rapids
team I I see now I'm not supposed to say
in video rapids because it's a community
and there's other developers but the
rapids libraries started by Nvidia but
they're built built around the arrow
memory format for representing data
frames on the on the GPU so super
exciting stuff to see so much kind of
GPU analytics code getting built so it's
been exciting to work with all of these
companies and different open-source
collaborators around around the world so
I want to tell you kind of briefly about
things that I'm focused on and things
that we want to build because there
might be there might be some things that
you run into in your work and the
biggest way that you know a lot of that
Python users and and developers can help
is that we want to hear from you about
the problems that you're facing if
something is slow if it doesn't work
well there's something you can't do
something seems too hard
like that's feedback that's really
helpful so that we can help you know we
can prioritize and take into account you
know the use cases in the experiences of
people out in the community because
ultimately like we're building software
that we want you know to be widely
adopted we're not I'm not building
software for a product or anything I've
no ulterior motives like I just want to
see you know the ecosystem develop and
become more more efficient so so we're
spending a lot of time on file formats
that's things like I'll mention the file
formats we we have started building a
high-performance messaging framework
called flight of give you a few words
about that we are we're helping we are
collaborating with folks building an LVM
array expression compiler that
specialized for the Aero
memory layout we are going to be
starting to build a an in-memory query
engine that's similar to an analytic
database engine that can be run in
process and embedded in many different
places obviously what we want to make
sure everything works really well for
kind of the major data science
communities and Python and our so this
is you know really interested in how the
open source project works but you know
we we release software we build stuff
I'll let you look at this so one thing
that's been interesting I want to
mention about things that we're doing is
that one way we've been growing the
project is by recruiting people working
on prod on problems that are one step
away from arrow but where the you know
the essentially the work that people are
doing is almost the same maybe they're
already using arrow or they could be
using arrow with a little bit of effort
and saying like why don't we join forces
and work together to solve common
problems and build you know libraries
that we can ship you know as as part of
the same ecosystem and so so we've been
that's part of how we've grown to so
many programming languages is by
identifying groups of open-source
developers who started building
something that is kind of already
effectively in the aero ecosystem but
they're working independently and say
hey you know we've got this community
here it's an Apache project open
governance and it's independent let's
work together and and and and kind of
have a cohesive communities that's been
really it's been a lot of work for me
it's been a lot of paperwork but it's
it's been very rewarding so on on the
file format side I think that I assume
that a lot of you are familiar with
these file formats the requirements are
being driven in large part and I'm a
stop and take questions soon but the
requirements to being driven part by
these are the format's that are used in
modern data warehousing in the cloud and
in hittin the Hadoop world so we need to
be able to read and write all of those
as efficiently as possible project where
I just started working on and in late
last year that I'm really excited about
is standardizing data transport in a
distributed system so like the rest of
the world we've you know we were buying
in on G RPC which is Google's messaging
network library really great piece of
software so what we were doing is you
know you connect a client to a server
and you request a data set and that data
set gets streamed via G RPC in a
sequence of arrow messages that are
using the arrow protocol and we did some
low-level work in G RPC so that we can
receive the message and begin to compute
on it without having to do any D
serialization so there is like Network
cost but basically we want to saturate
the network and not have any
serialization happening on either side
so compared with some other protocols
like some some cool things we can do is
parallel parallel retrieval so instead
of having one data node you have many
data nodes and so a client could be
fetching a large data set from many
different servers on a network and that
can provide scalability in a scenario
where you want to distribute large data
sets to many different clients and where
the data is maybe shard it across many
different many different servers another
very exciting project is Gandiva which
is named after the legendary bow of
Arjun in Hindu mythology if I have that
right so it's a very fancy bow that can
shoot arrows very fast and so Sodra me
oh-hoo-hoo is one of our main you know
one of the major collaborators on the
project started this project it's
written in C++ is LLVM and it's its
focus is on evaluating the the
computations that are part of the select
part of a sequel query and the where
block and so these are often bottlenecks
and aware you know people worth sequel
systems will will try to squeeze out CPU
cycles to compute those as efficiently
as possible
so Jeremy O's written in Java there's a
limit to how fast you can go in Java so
and
hence LVM so so it's really exciting
that from a Java system so because we
have Java libraries and C++ libraries
that are representing data in RAM in the
exact same way so a java-based database
engine can send a data set along with a
description of the computation it wants
to perform as like a as a just a general
it has a serialized representation of
expressions so they're sent over as a
protocol buffer that expression is
compiled with LLVM and the cool thing is
that even though the data was allocated
in Java we can act on it in process in
C++ without any copying so even though
there's J and I it's just sending
pointers and so it says hey C++ runtime
compiled this thing here's my pointers
you know run this thing allocate some
memory you know send it back so
traditionally sharing data between the
JVM and Python and the C++ world would
be impossible but it turns out it's not
impossible it's just a lot of work
because you have to define this you know
data protocol and like memory format and
like there's like you know seven layers
of technology that we've had to build to
make all this make all this possible
yeah
boring stuff we need we need to work
with the cloud so it is what it is but
anyway I'm going to stop here and take a
few questions but so this is a it's been
a really exciting project for me
in particular now that you know we've
gotten out of the early stage where it
was you know you know I had the
experience of doing make Durer a bunch
of times and starting a brand new
codebase and so you know now we have a
fast-growing community and all these
programming languages and people all of
the world so so a very exciting time and
I think the next few years are going to
be really cool
I'm glad that to have sort of the Ursa
Labs nonprofit arrangements so that so I
can prioritize the needs of the open
source world and also work with
corporations who want to sponsor the
project so if you have the ability to
sponsor or know anyone who can sponsor
please let me know otherwise I will see
you on github Thanks
thank us any questions I thank you for
for coming to Miami the question that I
have is any known company having are
already in production yeah so the Sodra
mio so they they they're the first
production users of arrow from like very
early very early days and so I mean
Jeremy was a product but they you know
it's a distributed database system and
it's it's being used and I don't have
their customer list but it's uh it's
being used in production in many in many
places the aro libraries are being used
in production by Python people at a
pretty high rate as far as I can tell
we're we're at somewhere around like a
million installs month-over-month which
is quite a lot so I think the two
Biggie's cases there are reading and
writing
Parkay files and storing and memory
mapping large data sets or moving them
around also kind of using arrows being
used in production with spark so I think
if you're a data bricks customer you can
use arrow and production on data bricks
if you're using spark 2.3 or higher you
can install all this and run production
spark jobs that use they use arrow but
think this customer kind of contributor
list is I need to update it but you know
we have you know we have folks from
Alibaba and financial that are using you
know uber as a user like I don't know I
probably heard of some of these
companies like it's but
yeahit's I would say the diversity of
use is increasing and that's and that's
a good thing as far as growing the
developer community there's a lot of
software written to use numpy do you
have any sort of vision for how to
either port or replicate that well I
guess numpy is is designed for a
different for a different use case so
for example multi-dimensional arrays we
don't we don't think multi-dimensional
arrays so this is this is about tables
and an analytics so data is primarily
one-dimensional it comes through is like
a stream of as a stream of chunks and so
kind of the you know it's intended to
work in tandem with numpy and things you
know tensor flow and things they're
working with multi-dimensional arrays so
it's a complementary thing not a
replacement that makes sense
first off I'm super stoked about arrow
like the spec looks really awesome and
I'm really excited to use it in a
painters data frame one question that I
had about future directions if there
were any I've read most of the spec and
I was really excited to see nullable
data in like a bit or a mask and that
was I think that was one of your points
in your 10 things i hate about paying
this talk is like yeah weird and old
data is in pandas yeah I didn't I didn't
mention that here but it's I think I
should add that to the slide little data
an old data is weird
in pandas and so addressing the where's
that slide somewhere up here yeah so
I'll add it to this slide but yeah
addressing the kind of weird rough edges
and inconsistencies with with null data
was yeah it was also big was was a big
motivation so so an arrow you know
there's so there's a bit for each value
the bit is on if it's non null and off
if it's if it's null one of the cool
things about that is that if you have a
batch of data that has no nulls you can
just skip checking for nulls and you
know if you have you can use hardware
operations to count really quickly so I
wrote like a blog post about this
recently that I mean basically we should
stop using Sentinel values and use bit
bits instead anyway but by extension I
guess my question was taking nullity to
the for this degree where you have like
really sparse data and this came up in
Richter's talk yesterday I've tried to
use like that pandas sparse data frame
before and found it to be kind of not it
looked like kind of unloved like it
wasn't being developed to really
actively and I was wondering if there
were plans to incorporate sparse data
into arrow and then via that pandas
later yeah I I think that I think that's
farce the sparse objects in pandas are
even are even planned for deprecations
and
also sorry to hear that but I think the
way that we would I think the way that
we would address though we would address
sparse sparse data in a narrow is with
run-length encoding and so it's been
it's been discussed but so far there
there isn't a proposal around like how
to incorporate it into into the
specification and so I think there's one
thing to say you run run length and code
data in memory a lot of database systems
already do this but I think the real
question is if you want to be able to
send run length encoding data from one
system to another and so that's where we
would have to do some some like evolve
the specification to accommodate that
there's also kind of the desire to
compress data on the wire and so far
we've we've been concerned with like
random access memory mapable
representation and and not dealing with
compression but that's also like there's
a JIRA open about it but that's
something that we eventually have to
have in the in the protocol so I have
like two small questions the first one
is do you see any sort of like pandas
rewrite or ideally in the future is
gonna be a rewrite of any of these
libraries or it's always going to stay
kind of in the fence and in this outer
layer as a front-end and the second one
is if you can like really quickly tell
us about the Apache Incubator out happen
how are gone into a patch and what's are
the benefits just completely out of
curiosity okay so the so the first
question around rewriting pandas that
seems unlikely so there's a couple of
things so pandas is an extremely large
library and the way it's the way it's
designed
it's a it is not very amenable to
extremely large datasets in the way just
the way that the library works and so
we've spent a lot of time like the
pandas core developers now like we all
met up last summer
in Austin and we this is one of the
topics that we that we discussed so I
think that the the consensus is that we
want you know we want pandas to continue
to be like a hugely featured like super
big Swiss Army knife of working with
data with a very wide you know large
collection of AP is very flexible for
working with you know low you know low
gigabytes of data and on down in memory
obviously you know desk data frame and
other projects will continue to use
pandas like as a black box for doing out
of core algorithms and so that's been
going really well but I think my my
interest is in building a essentially
companion project might be one way of
putting it but a library that's designed
for working with very large data sets
and data sets that are largely on disk
where you need to select filter
aggregate join essentially more like a
database but embedded and in process
rather than being a database system that
you have to run and that and that's that
we all be Aero powered and something
that could be used together with pandas
in parallel of course I think there's
some parts of pandas where like we have
code that we're maintaining like that
could be retrofitted with stuff that's
coming from the arrow libraries and you
know that will mean less code to
maintain for pandas and in better
performance as well in some cases so
it's kind of a bit of both but I think
like a grand kind of API compatible
rewrite of pandas is not in the cards
the second thing is so we we decided to
do a project in the Apache Software
Foundation mainly to head off concerns
about
kind of kind of governance and like
competition amongst vendors so like a
number of the individuals who helped
start the project worked for big data
companies that are in direct market
competition with each other in one of
the ways that the the ASF helps is by
providing like a neutral ground for
competing vendors like the people that
work there distill collaborate and say
like oh we can't you know we can't have
one company with a ton of money come in
and take over the project like the ASF
like helps protect the other developers
from corporations with lots of money so
we yeah so we formed we split some IP
out of the Apache drill project to
create a new top-level project in 2016
and so we were kind of a top-level
project from the from the get-go which
which there does some of the trials of
the incubation process that a lot of
projects often have to go through all
right final question here do you have
any remarks on the new data class
feature and is it three point six or
three point seven and its usefulness in
the pandas workflow work panas workflows
arrow or other interesting applications
of that new feature I haven't looked I
haven't looked carefully enough to have
strong opinions about it I will say that
I think it's good that the language
moratorium has been lifted and that new
features are being added to Python I
mean I think if data classes can be used
to make like nicer ORM like features
like I think it like there were already
maybe some people are in the room are
familiar with traits like anyone you
ever used traits before where trait
'let's
so this was like a long time ago there
was essentially something very similar
to data classes where it would do type
validation of attributes and if you set
a value that was the wrong type it would
error things like that and maybe adding
data classes seems maybe like a more eye
maybe you have the feature set wrong but
it seems like it's it's a good thing so
and if it can be made to work well kind
of together with pandas or other tools
like this then that's great so thanks
again Wes yeah thank you so we've got
another session of talk starting in here
and then a tutorial starting at 2:15
might run a couple minutes late to give
you guys more of a break